bro i also have to bring up that lewis
hamilton cliff
uh it's is this one dude
that's what this one
you're gonna you're gonna howl this is
good this could be a cringe in it of
itself man we're gonna get twenty oh
yeah yeah i watch this it's like lewis
fans are
crazy man losers pretty good crazy yeah
i didn't realize
how big this guy was oh he's massive
huge i was like i watched the video and
i was like oh he's got a balenciaga
sweater on so
new tab lewis hamilton net worth 285
million bucks yeah yeah
bazillion trillion bazillion trillion
the
bts of racing dude
bro
[Laughter]
i have jokes for this is someone dm me
this video as well i had a [ __ ]
hilarious joke
write it right off the rip what what is
the angle
i i'm saying what people film like from
here
dude this is a jacob sartorius video bro
totally
the hoodie popped the look in his eyes
right yeah yeah
he has a ring light on
in his view but it's a it's
warm light yeah real warm light you got
the you got the bicolored ring
ring light yeah exactly it does two
color temps
the dog the [ __ ] forearm extended
like he really has to frame it like he's
pinning you down come on man
yeah oh that's what it is that's exactly
what it looks like it looks like he's
choking us
hi everyone i hope you're all well
i know i've not been in touch this past
week but it's definitely been one of the
hardest uh
weeks that i've that i've had for
somebody grabbing your meat dude
the arm is like the arm position is
crazy
all he need all he needed to do was do
one
little like yeah yeah
dude dude he's trying the hardest by the
way this is the guy that we were talking
about that had coveted okay
that's what he's talking about the race
car driver is recovering from covet
he's trying so hard not to lick his lips
this has been one of the toughest weeks
of my whole life ah
this one this is one of the hardest
weeks of my life
this is the hardest i've been this has
been one of the most throbbing weeks of
my life
let it finish honestly i feel like i'm
just pulsating right now
with the desire to get over this virus
um it's just been focusing on recovering
and trying to get back uh in shape so i
can get back in the car and race
the final race in abu dhabi um i woke up
today feeling great
and got my first workout in so i just
wanted to send you guys a message of
positivity let you know that i'm okay
and wait wait wait we're just right here
it's right here
one of you for sending me the amazing
messages and
and videos and um i really really
appreciate it
that doesn't say nudes i just want to
say that is not
nudes if that is not beautiful people
thank you for hearing all the messages
and those videos god
in those amazing videos what videos
what who are you what why are you
watching
whose videos are you like what fans
videos are you watching
you're going to your dms and watching
like
if this is not the face of i just got a
hundred
million nudes oh yeah for having covid
covid nudes
well let's see what else he says and i
hope that wherever you are you're
staying positive
and fighting through uh whatever that
you're facing
and uh i hope that i can get back in the
car soon
oh my god that look down yeah hope that
i can
get back in the car soon um are you
filming a rap video
what is that bro
he kind of looks like like he should be
an r b singer or something like that man
lewis is you know he's a good looking
there's no denying that
so whoever sent me this as well was like
oh yeah he definitely was getting his
dick sucked right there
oh right here oh my god
it'll be so funny right at the very end
you heard
[Laughter]
you just see the top of someone's head
just pop up from the bottom of the frame
thank you all whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
remember that stay positive
[Laughter]
she is mate what is her back down
geez stay positive i just see [ __ ]
spits on it
oh my god thank you all the to all the
fat the wonderful fans for the wonderful
message
no she does the [ __ ]
cheers thank you love y'all
i'm telling you right now there's going
to be so many louis fans that comment on
this like how dare you
you sick pervert like david oh come on
it's
funny how can you not look at this and
say it's funny
dude it's so funny man this guy has the
[ __ ] life dude yeah come on
that's the life yeah i just uh i'm
sending you guys love
yo someone please take this and and
confident comping
right at the end writer says send in
love right when he smiles there put in
the little
he's like i'm about to send some love
right now too i'm about to send someone
else some love
and i'm about to send you some love
right now and you some love and
use some love ah
man the [ __ ] dude it
like holy [ __ ] that's like a thirst trap
ran through a pr firm
yeah you could show a little forearm
louis
um wear something a little bit more
nighttime
you know and um preferably after a
workout
you might be a little short of breath so
it might just give your voice
just a subtle
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah you
want yeah yeah you want
you want to shoot it at night time but
you you want those
incandescent lights you want that warm
lighting so it reminds people of being
in a sauna with you
yeah or you know bedside lighting that's
really what you want to go for
what would have been really cash is if
at the end of that video he reached over
and he had like a little
pull tab for a like a lamp and he just
he just pulled it out good swimming love
good night
good night
oh yeah yeah yeah
and the video just keeps it's a real
it's a seven minute instagram reel
this is him [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
somebody
oh oh i hit the bottom of my lungs
thank you good night
positive stay positive
stay positive sending all my love
in your beautiful videos
[Laughter]
is this the first 60 seconds of him
the remaining six and a half minutes is
just
[Laughter]
i would like to inform you all i regret
to inform you that i've accidentally
uploaded this video of me
absolutely destroying this young this is
destroying this woman's cheeks and i
would just like to apologize in advance
for what you're about to see
oh my god oh my god yeah you thought
you thought that you guys thought the
jay alvarez tape was crazy watch this oh
my god man
i want dude i want someone to do the
incel version of that video
it was just them in a blow-up doll in
like a dark closet
yeah he's coconut oiling the you know
like i didn't even see that part man i
saw a nut sack and i'm like i'm good man
i
really never wanted to know this dude's
nuts look like
[ __ ] like you had a hot wing man
that's funny that's what louis does to
you so louis does
you